we live in a liberal society small-l
that means we're committed to values
like free speech and toleration it means
we try to create an open forum and it
also means we understand there going to
be some obnoxious and sociopathic and
racist and anti-semitic and homophobic
people in our midst and to some degree
we not only allow that but we embrace it
because it reminds us that these ideas
are there and it reminds us that we got
to refute them and we got to stay on our
guard as a gay person I want to know
where these homophobes are and I want to
have the opportunity to refute and
debunk them I don't want to put them
into hiding because then they'll emerge
all the stronger at the other end but
there's this age-old debate you know
what happens if you're so tolerant that
the intolerant people gain the upper
hand in society should you be tolerant
of people who themselves would not be
tolerant what about the neo-nazi now
this is someone who if they come to
power would shut me down so I'm supposed
to advocate their freedom knowing that
they would never advocate mine this is
an age-old challenge it's a hard
question but right now in America it's
an easy question because here's the
thing the important thing is not that
every individual in a society in a
country of 300 million people should be
tolerant that's impossible
that will never happen humans aren't
wired that way the important thing is
that the rules of the society force
people to subject their ideas to testing
so a crazy bigot with a conspiracy
theory will not get their ideas taught
in the Universities or in the textbooks
in the public schools they'll be
marginalised by the same token these
societies also commit to free speech if
you have those rules in society as a
whole it's going to be a pretty safe
place to express intolerance
now if you don't have those institutions
solidly in place if you don't have
courts that will vigorously enforce the
First Amendment freedom of speech if you
don't have universities and an
intellectual culture which will hold the
line on fake knowledge and say no we're
only teaching true stuff here then
intolerance becomes much more dangerous
because it becomes much more possible
for the intolerant actually to gain
control of power in the society years
ago I was trying to think through the
approaches that people have to how we
talk to each other in a complicated
country like ours and how we decide
what's true and what's not and I made a
distinction between pluralism and purism
that seems to capture a lot of what's
going on pluralists I put myself in this
camp believe that the way you find truth
is not by eliminating prejudice from
society because we're all prejudiced
it's part of being human we all have a
point of view we all have pre-existing
ideas we're all stubborn and very
attached to the things that we think are
true rather the way you arrive at truth
as a society is you pit the prejudices
against each other so that means you
don't want to have unprejudiced people
you just need to have a lot of different
prejudices you need intellectual
diversity and then those things will
talk to each other they'll persuade each
other sometimes they'll conflict and
criticize each other but it's through
that process that as a group as a
country as a society we learn what's
true that I said well you know there's a
very different group that's not the way
for example a church operates there
you've got an idea of some doctrines
that are believed to be true and that's
that's a function of they would say a
higher power but it's also how we in
that community define our community we
believe in the divinity of Jesus Christ
that he died for our sins we also
believe that for example
sexuality is a sin no one's born gay all
kinds of things for example a religious
community might believe and there are
many secular communities that also have
these kinds of sacred beliefs things
that bind them together it could be anti
racism for example something that
absolutely no one questions and if you
do you're going to be shun now I happen
to agree with anti racism but what I
don't agree with is the implicit
attitude that lies behind some of these
communities which is we already know
what the truth is
and because we know the truth we
shouldn't tolerate or accept falsehood
we need to be pure as communities in our
commitment to the truth we need to drive
out and exterminate prejudice and
wrongheaded ideas and it's through that
process that we'll come to knowledge we
are fortunate enough to live in a
country where pluralism is well
established under law and well accepted
by the American public so right now we
are nowhere near a line where we would
have to make the kinds of decisions that
Germany had to make in the early 1930s
we can just say yes in America it's
legal to be intolerant may not be right
it may not get you accepted or respected
but absolutely it's legal and it should
be legal
[Music]